hello everyone round seven on the st.
Louis rapid tournament just finished and
Gary Kasparov was playing against David
navara and it was a beautiful game
straight from the opening a very sharp
line played and well you'll just have to
see it it was almost like Karpov was
playing at tennis Kasparov Kasper goes
for we have c6 the caro-kann d4 d5 and
Kasparov lanes c5 Bishop to f5 Knight to
c3 g6 and now g4 a very sharp line by
the spiral Bishop to g6 and now Knight
not going for h4 but nice to eat - now
preparing that nice to jump to Eaton
janta at 4 we have c5 by navara Bishop
to e3 nice to e7
and now s4 and number of plays h5 and
this gives Kasparov a great idea he
plays at 5 and I'm attacking that Bishop
and also the ecig spawn he captures a
captures on f5 and of course power plays
g5 and I'll completely lock this Bishop
out of the game I will have a knight BTW
c6 Knight to f4 we have 8 6 Bishop - G -
because power doesn't want to really
capture this bishop ever because it's
the world completely useless see captors
on d4 Bishop captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and queen capture 74 we
have a knight to c6 and the Queen to f2
and Bishop to b4 and here Kasparov goes
for the queenside castle so it's going
to be a very very fun game we have
Bishop captures on c3 be captures on c3
and now Queen to a5 going for that a to
pawn and also for the c3 pawn as far
place rook captures on d5 and Navarre
plays Queen captures on c3 and we have a
queen to c5 now offering offering like
to get this Quinte 1 check although it
doesn't really accomplish anything so
here after a while and Navarre decided
to trade the Queen's the Queen captures
on c5 rook captures on c5 and okay we
got a very nice endgame here Navarro is
a pawn up but his tradition is
completely terrible this Bishop is like
he's like a piece down so we have
castles Bishop captures on c6 big
captures on c6 and are not capturing the
form the playing rook to d1 we have a to
be 8 and here is well probably the best
move of the game because fireplace c4
and this c4 is a great move
it prevents this it's little counter to
this rook to b8 which prevents the rook
from coming to b5 and also from going to
be for to harass this night so no more
plays rook F to d8 we have rough to be 6
by Gaspar now King to f8 and our rook
captures on c6 we have root D to c8 and
I'll just simply came to see to
improving the position and Navarre plays
h4 so if this night ever moves from f4
he will be able to able to activate this
Bishop with the h5 square coz power
plays the rook captures on Pietro
captures on c8 and not safe with King to
c3 and already you can see that this
Bishop is still completely trapped and
because power has a free entry and well
this is this is a winning position for
white Navarre plays a5 protecting the
spawn and because power goes for it he
wants to grab this pawn as well which it
isn't the bad move we have rook to b8
and I looked captures an 85 and rook the
b1 now activating his own root X bar
plays c5 and we have rook to e1
attacking that e5 pawn rook to e8 checks
King t7 rook to e7 check and king te 8
and we have a nice a d3 and this night
the d3 move was well there was a better
move here the better move was east 6 but
Turkish probably didn't have enough time
to calculate this as it would require a
lot of calculating after e6 this a 6
pawn cannot be captured because the
bishop would be hanging and well the
continuation would be something like
rook to d1
c6 now rook the c1 and now King to d4
given up this c6 pawn but this is
very hard to do when you have little
time on the clock rook captures on c6
and now King to e5 rook the c5 and now
King to d6 and the well now you can see
that would an active King like that this
is completely winning for example rook
the c8 nice capture some g 6f garrison
g6 and now rook captures on g7 and there
isn't a lot there isn't much luck can do
here
for example check King t5 now attacking
that h2 pawn and now King to f6 and
black is in trouble is what is a
threatening checkmate and he can't
really grab any of these funds
that's just yet but this requires a lot
of calculating so after this King to
eight more Kasparov plays nice to d3 and
this allows Navarro some some good
counter play please rook to e3
now pinning this night and also
threatening f4 so Kasparov has to go
back he kind of waits to move here we
have a roofed h3 as attacking that h2
pawn and okay Kaspar pushes forward and
number our captures rook captures an h2
which check and even here this is a
completely winning position for Kasparov
he has to play his game to c3 but this
power plays King to e3 if Kasparov
simply played King to c3 although this
this also requires some calculating with
with low time after King to d8e six we
have F captures and e6 and now simply
nice to f4 and well as you can see the
skin cannot go anywhere near this pawn
the thread is Knight captures here on e6
check and if King created and simply
rotate checkmate so King the king will
not to be able to stop this pawn but
because power didn't see this so after
work - H - check
he clicking the e3 and well this allows
Navarro a lot of counter play we have
roped the c2 and now his rook is behind
as far as pawn so this isn't good for
Gary now cuz powerful is e 6 we have h3
nice the b4 we have f4 check King C 5 H
2 we have wrote a check
10:37 rope to a chase and are protecting
that bone from queening rope to d8
erupted interject came to c5 Bishop to
e4 and are protecting that green square
but Cafaro pushes c7 we have a bishop to
b7 and King to c6 not attacking the
bishop Navarre place here Bishop the b8
and well this is a this is a draw
position although with with such so
little time on the clock it's it's hard
to play this to a draw and the spawn of
captures the Bishop rook rook captures
on c8 which allows h1 Queen and here his
power plays rook to e8 chick now the
King has to capture and now c8 Queen for
Kasparov and because part of thought
that he was completely winning here
he saw that after King to e7 he plays
Knight to c6 check and what Kasparov saw
that would happen was King to d6 and now
Queen to d7 checkmate but to his shock
and horror after Knight to c6 and
Navarre played Queen captures on physics
which check and because peril probably
considered this but he saw after King
captures Queens and simply rook to c2
picks up the Queen but he plays Queen
captures on c6 and I guess he thought he
was up a queen and then when a bar
played worked to d6 then he was he
started shaking his head and the world
it was a sad game for Kasparov as well
this for pawn is simply too far down the
board and whatever white plays this is
completely winning
so after noir played wrote the d6
agaricus power resigned the game and
well we'll see how how round 8 goes for
for the OL champion so that's it for
this game
thank you for watching as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here and
I'll see you soon maybe even today